I'm a huge fan of John Mulaney's,
as I think we all are,
but you do a great John
Mulaney impression.
I think for him, I was just kind of...
I think I watched his
stand ups, a few specials,
and I was thinking of
like, he always goes,
"I've noticed, when I wear my pants,
sometimes I do have ants in
my pants, and that's a saying,
but it's true to my life."
It's always saying like
I notice something.
An observation.
(Conan and Melissa laughing)
And then, yeah.
He's got kind of an old
fashioned sort of diction,
and I mean he could be in Vaudeville.
It could be 1922 when here's
John Mulaney, you know.
Yeah, you saw it on the SNL at home.
He was in the Masterclass sketch,
where he's a master at putting on suits,
putting together your tie and your button,
look like you're going to
your First Holy Communion.
And he saw it and he really liked it.
And I noticed he does a certain
thing when's he's walking.
He goes...
You know?
(Conan laughing)
You know what, one of the
impressions that you do,
I'm just talking about how
you'll pick an unusual target,
The Little Rascals.
The Little Rascals is something
that I grew up watching
and it's from the 1930's,
but they would show it a lot
on local television when I was a kid.
That's how I know it.
I didn't even know that someone your age
would be aware of The Little Rascals.
We would rent The Little
Rascals VHS, the classics.
Oh good, okay.
But the past few months, my mom,
she let me borrow her Little Rascal DVDs,
and she said, "give 'em back
'cause these are my favorite."
(woman laughing)
I'm not gonna keep 'em.
No.
Yeah but-
And so you learned, you
started watching those
and I'm told you do a
Little Rascals impression
or an impression of The Little Rascals.
Well 'cause I was trying
to watch Little Rascals
and I couldn't even
get through an episode.
I don't know what they're saying.
You can't hear it it's so
crinkly and old, you know?
They're just like (mumbling).
Hamburger.
(Conan and Melissa laughing)
That's all I could hear so.
Yeah, that's pretty much all it is.
And also long takes.
They'll do like...
They'll be visuals of like Spanky looking
or Alfalfa looking at
something or somebody,
Buckwheat, I don't know,
they'll just be looking at
something and they'll be like...
And the camera will be
on them way too long
and you think they just had
more time in the 1930's.
You know, comedy now is
like (snapping fingers)
it's like this and back then,
someone would do something funny
and they'd cut to someone else going...
(Melissa laughing)
Yeah.
And you're like, what?
You just had more time
during the Depression.
Was the film expensive then?